bottom line is you go on the road the
division especially Monday night
football against a team that has a ton
to play for it right there still they're
still fighting for a playoff spot and
you know you know this is it's gonna be
a battle and bottom line is do you make
the plays the end of game to win the
game drew brees quarterback of the New
Orleans Saints one of the last men
standing when it comes to the MVP
conversation his team gets it done on
Monday Night Football they've rebounded
well Peter from that primetime game that
we saw a couple of weeks ago in Dallas
and now the the Saints moving in the
right direction winning football games
and setting themselves up for the number
one seed and if the Saints get the
number one seed that means the Rams are
gonna have to go back there the Bears
are gonna have to go back there anyone
if the Cowboys are to make it to a spot
where they'd be a rematch I'm sure the
Saints would welcome them to New Orleans
and say let's play this game again but
in our building instead of yours you
know the tough thing about New Orleans
in January and you know I've seen some
games in New Orleans in January is that
it's just absolutely cacophonous it's
and look that word up America it's loud
and the one thing about the Saints right
now that is different Mike and you
mention it at the top is defense and I
think Dennis Allen the defensive
coordinator realizes right now that he
has about four or five different ways
that he can play a game as you look at
what what is the incredible number that
you're looking at right now at least in
my opinion is that the Saints have never
been one of these teams that can unleash
pass rusher after pass rusher at you now
they can't 28 sacks in the last six
weeks this is a premier defensive team
and now they can hold a decent team on
the road to nine points and I say decent
because Mike Carolina's just weird
ballclub right now and as long as Cam
Newton you know it has you know he
clearly has something wrong with his
shoulder and as long as Cam Newton
and whole and you're asking Christian
McCaffrey to be everything I mean it was
like old-time football where he's the
quarterback to that team that team
certainly does not deserve to make the
playoffs no absolutely not and just
think not that long ago they were six
and two and we were looking forward to
these two games in three weeks between
and actually two games in thirteen days
between the Saints and the Panthers as
something that could determine the NFC
South much in the way that this Chargers
Chiefs rivalry is is driving the AFC
West and the number one seed in the AFC
to a conclusion but the Panthers have
fallen apart from six and two to six and
eight and you're right Cam Newton's
shoulder isn't right that they they hung
in there as best they could but they
just can't get it done and I think a lot
of that has to do with Cam Newton's
inability to get the ball down the field
when you take the D fall off the table
Peter it's a lot easier to defend a team
you don't have to worry about getting
beaten over the top you can keep all
your 11 players in a fairly tight window
and you can just shut an offense down I
stayed up last night Mike wrongly
because I was really curious to see what
Cam Newton said after the game in he was
not at all specific and and and I think
that there are a lot of people right now
who are looking at him saying well
somebody knows what's wrong with this
guy's shoulder because he just of all
he's not accurate second of all he's not
thrown with any juice on the ball at all
and he threw a bunch of worm burners
late last night and in the fourth
quarter and and Mike I mean they need to
get their quarterback right that's all
there is to it if they don't get their
quarterback right they really don't have
a lot to play for right now yeah and you
think about whatever it's gonna take
whether it's rehab whether it's surgery
start now there's no reason to delay the
process and get this guy ready for the
off season program in 2019 let's hear
from Cam directly some of the things he
had to say after Monday night's loss
about the condition of his shoulder
here's Cam Newton
and I wish I could say what the injury
is because I really don't know what it
is either you know doesn't matter how
much you push no matter how much you
like I said ice you know
anti-inflammatories you take in the oven
trust me I did it acupuncture massages
it's just not it's not been a time that
I haven't you know a night went by
without me getting some type of work
down on my arm and you know we just
don't have the strength he ultimately
said he wouldn't be bothered by sitting
out the final two games of the season if
it comes to it he's not looking forward
to the conversation but if that's what
happens that's what happens and it makes
sense at this point with the Panthers
essentially done for the year they have
to figure out what's wrong with Newton
is this another andrew luck situation
where we would see this guy gone for an
extended period of time I don't know but
the sooner they get it really figured
out and fixed the better off they'll be
I want to take this back to the Saints
though looking at their schedule they
had three straight games on the road
they lost to Dallas they want at Tampa
they won at Charlotte now they come home
and again with one more win they lock
down the 1 seed Peter this is a team
that may not leave New Orleans until
they pack up for the short trip to
Atlanta for the Superbowl their home for
two regular season games by week two
postseason games if they continue to
advance and if they advance to the
Superbowl they could drive to Atlanta
not only that Mike if you think about it
you know they're not playing outside the
rest of the year you know they have a
maximum of five games and they're all in
domes and at least four of those games
would they'll have a pronounced huge
home-field advantage because of the
noise and the Superdome so there's no
team in the NFL right now nobody even
close who set up to have as clear a path
to the Super Bowl as the Saints yes and
you know as we are looking at all these
other teams and and we are the Rams
really any good or the Chiefs flawed can
the Chargers get it together what's
wrong with the Patriots the one team
that is standing out right now that we
had forgotten about in part because they
didn't play this Sunday we had that
lingering image of the Thursday night
loss to the Cowboys
to kind of pop the balloon the bottom
line is the Saints we know they have the
capability on offense they're proving
they have the capability on defense
they're balanced and they're gonna have
that advantage think about it they can
throw the suitcase down in that room in
the basement where they keep their
suitcases they don't need them for the
next month more than a month it's
December 18th then I'm gonna have to
pack up again until an even even even if
they you know that well I guess there's
a way they could lose with it at home
and have to go on the road you know if
they're gonna be home they're gonna be
home for the duration and I that's a
huge mental advantage going into the
last couple of weeks of the season while
all these other teams are still
scratching and clawing yes they still
have to take care of business yes they
have to win one of these final two games
but they're gonna be able to be in the
comfort of their own home the comfort of
their practice facility the comfort of
their own bed and that is an amazing
advantage that no other team can say
they have at this point Peter and Mike
the one thing I would be concerned about
and we've seen this before we saw it
with the Colts the Dungy polian Manning
Colts we saw it with the Mike McCarthy
Aaron Rodgers Packers you know at this
time of year especially if let's say the
Saints were to clinch everything you
know this week I think it's possible
right for them to clinch everything this
week yes it is yeah and so if they
clinch everything this week you one
thing you got to be careful about is
taking your foot off the grate the gas
so much that you don't play your guys in
the last game of the year against
Carolina and then you have a bye week
and then basically guys have been away
from football serious football for three
weeks and here come pick a team the
Cowboys the Bears whoever into town and
they're primed because they've been
playing every week and so I I think
Peyton they'll do the right thing I
think Sean Peyton will do the right
thing but that's the one thing I'd be
cognizant of watching the Saints and
talking about this great path that they
have that's an excellent point Peter
because if you do take your foot off the
gas for even one week and you have that
bye week it's a
long time between games where you have
really been bringing it at a high level
and you'll be facing a team in that
divisional round that will have had to
most likely scratch and claw all the way
through to the end and that will have
played a playoff game within a week
before showing up to play you and under
the current playoff tree assuming the
Saints end up with the 1 seed it's most
likely going to be the Cowboys the
Seahawks or the Vikings that show up and
I think any of those three teams could
pop them in the mouth early change the
narrative get them a little flat-footed
and the next thing you know you're down
14 to nothing and that special season is
just a quarter and a half away from
going up in smoke we've seen that before
in recent years those top seeds have
found a way to hold serve at home and
maybe one of the reasons our teams are
getting away from this idea that we're
going to deliberately shut it down
prematurely because even though you're
incurring that injury risk I think it's
better to have all your guys in full
sweat and ready to go and lathered up
and not complacent or not just off their
game in any way when they're getting
ready to face a team that is on their
game because they just want to playoff
game you know it's the one thing over
the years Mike that you know both of us
have heard it from Tony Dungy you know
he's not sorry about about doing that
Mike McCarthy has said the same thing I
mean I just have to agree to disagree I
think that in those situations you
cannot have I remember before the
Packers lost to the Giants most recently
2011 whatever year was before the
Packers lost to the Giants I remember
the Green Bay Packers had 19 days for
their veteran for that veteran team to
go without playing football seriously
and they came out and they looked awful
the pate the Colts did it once or twice
as well so I think Peyton the one thing
I know about Sean Peyton is that he pays
attention to history be certainly
respects history and I think won't make
that mistake if it if it comes that last
week particularly with his offense
because
I think there's so many young pieces on
this offense there's so many young guys
you know the veterans they brought in
didn't work out Dez Bryant because of
injury Brandon Marshall because of age
or whatever but they have to get these
guys like Kincaid and and car and all
these young guys you know Smith they got
to get these guys ready to play at this
level so III think I think Sean Payton
is gonna do the right thing in play in
week 17
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports